[Music]
it's been a crazy week in america so
let's find out
what happened nickelodeon aired its kids
pick the president's special this week
with
former vice president joe biden winning
by seven points
even crazier the kids had to wait up to
four
hours to vote poor kids
that's voter suppression president trump
cast his vote in the 2020 election last
week at a library in florida
and was reportedly the only person
voting inside the building at the time
usually the trump campaign is always
lying but a library in four of
a library in florida being empty sounds
like the truth to me
see now you're making fun of people for
being dumb
but you can't say florida so
that's what you get that's called my
comeuppance now
in order to minimize the spread of the
coronavirus
scotland's government recently advised
citizens to avoid trick-or-treating this
year
while the u.s government advised people
to hand out candy like this
you you guys a lady in the trap these
children it's part of halloween
yeah the u.n high commissioner for human
rights said recently that
urgent and profound action needs to be
taken to combat systemic racism in the
u.s
girl said the anti-lynching bill
currently being held up on the congress
floor
that's right there's an anti-lynching
bill
being held up on the congress floor
cause some people like lynching
and some folks do not
a firefighter in tennessee who's over 6
feet and 11 inches tall
was recently certified as the world's
tallest
firefighter he also holds the record for
most cats saved
he just plucks him out see he's so tall
he just gets him oh he doesn't have to
talk like that but he does because he's
really tall he probably does though yeah
you're right
residents in texas recently called the
police on their neighbor because of his
halloween lawn decoration
which features 20 gallons of fake blood
20 gallons of blood or as women call it
day two
it's heavy flow day don't cut to tearing
you stay on me
i said heavy flow
while competing in a fishing tournament
a florida man recently caught a blue
catfish
weighing over 110 pounds said the
catfish
don't be telling my weight to everybody
rude
and finally a blue moon will reportedly
appear on halloween this year
and also anytime two white guys hang out
hey you unbelievable you got a paps
[Music]
i am so did you feel the privilege
and that was the monologue
derek what was your favorite part of the
monologue oh i loved all the bits with
jokes
oh good job me too smart
but telling jokes isn't free we rely on
ad revenue to keep the lights on
around here so now it's time for a word
from our sponsor
right the amber ruffin show is brought
to you by
guess who the republican edition instead
of
regular guess who people it's all famous
republicans
that sounds fun it's super fun okay i'll
start
is your person conservative uh
no uh they all are maybe try another
question
should you be more specific sure does
your person
come for money uh can you be more
specific
how about this is your person racist
yeah you're still not narrowing it down
all right four years ago during the
primaries was your person like
donald trump is terrible but then as
soon as trump was nominated they were
like
trump is the best can you be more
specific
is your person homophobic how homophobic
so homophobic you're like is he
can you be more specific okay i got it
is your person pro-life but then like
weirdly into the death penalty be more
specific does your person like guns
more specific did you ever see a picture
of your person with their whole family
and you could tell from that picture
that all their adult children hate them
you have to be more specific than that
this will never work
how is this game going to ever end you
haven't knocked down a single person
i need you to be more specific okay
oh i got it is your person
a minority ah yes mine too
oh are you clarence thomas
hi yes you know what eric that was fun
yeah guess who the republican edition
hours and hours and hours
and hours of fun for the whole family
and don't forget
guess who the democrat edition
are you someone who made a bunch of
promises of black people but then once
elected forgot all about them
you know what we're gonna be here all
night we need to move on you sure
yes you guys we have a lot of things to
talk about like
the fact that tomorrow is halloween and
if we're one day away from halloween
that means we're also one day away from
something else
people wearing offensive costumes
we here at the amber ruffin show were
wondering what we could do to stop
people from doing that
and we came up with an answer nothing
there's nothing we can do so instead we
wrote a song
so when you see someone in a terrible
costume you can pull this up on youtube
and play this
just for them if your costume
is an ethnicity then you're a piece of
[ __ ]
an uncreated and weirded freaking
walking turd
and now everybody knows it
so take your headdress sombrero and
blackened face throw them in the garbage
be your own damn race
cause this halloween party is not the
place
for your casual racism
hey if you can hear this song it's
because someone near you is
dressed as an ethnicity yes even though
it's 2020 some
man or woman thought it'd be a good idea
that's right some idiot put on a turban
or a fu manchu goatee and now we're
wondering if your parents are really
really rich or really really poor
uh tarik are you trying to whistle yeah
oh
just that you should know hope you do
better one last time
if your costume is an ethnicity
then you're a piece of [ __ ]
an uncreative and waited freaking
walking turd
and now everybody knows it
so take your headdress sombrero and
blackened face
throw them in the garbage be your own
damn race does this
halloween party is not the place for
your
casual racism
cause this halloween party is not the
place for
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
you